-Our next guest is
an Emmy-nominated actress
and comedian you know from shows
like "The Last Man on Earth"
and "BoJack Horseman."
She stars in "The Mysterious
Benedict Society,"
which premieres June 25th,
with str-- with two episodes -
excuse me -- streaming
exclusively on Disney+.
Let's take a look.
-And if any child is caugh
cheating, they will be executed.
-[ Gasps ]
-E-Excused.
Will be excused.
[ Clears throat ]
This test is going to be long,
and it's going to be difficult
-Ugh!
-Was I not clear
about the talking?
-Oh, uh, I just groaned.
-Well, now you've spoken again
You are excused.
-Uh --
-Mm.
-Please welcome back to the show
our good friend Kristen Schaal
Hello, Kristen.
-Oh, hi, Seth!
-This is historic.
I did not realize this.
This is your first Zoom
interview, and let me just say
your light looks fantastic
you look great.
-Thanks, Seth.
My makeup artist couldn't
make it today.
I'm not fishing, but, oh,
my God, I put these on myself.
And you have to go to school
These are not real.
-[ Laughs ]
-Yeah.
I got my own -- this week 'cause
I knew I was doing your show
I was at
the Burlington Coat Factory,
and in the checkout line,
they were selling
all of the glow lights?
What are those called?
The circle lights?
-Yeah, the ring lights.
-I finally bought one at the end
of the pandemic.
-I can't believe they had that
at the Burlington Coat Factory
What a wonderful place.
-They sell everything there,
Seth.
[ Laughter ]
And it was only $9.
-Well, I mean, you're gettin
$100 worth of light out of it.
So it's a steal.
-Thank you.
I do miss being in the studio.
Where was John Cena?
Like, it looked like he really
got put up nicely.
-Yeah. I do think
that you can sometimes --
I mean, your show -- by the way,
the clip of your show,
it looks wonderful.
It's obviously a high budget
But I'm guessing it does not
have the same promotional budget
as "The Fast and the Furious
movies.
-Yeah, I'm sort of
thinking that too,
mainly because my makeup artis
couldn't make it today.
[ Laughter ]
Did you --
I've never seen those movies
But they look like fun.
-I think they --
I have seen a few of them.
They're a lot of fun.
Much like your new show,
they're based on
a series of children's books
[ Laughter ]
-Someone did say that
a 9-year-old would write that.
Right? Or a little kid like,
"The car goes boom
and it goes burst
and everyone's like --"
[ Grunts ]
I have to watch it though.
I will watch it. I have to now
-I want to ask,
before I ask about the show,
your oldest is three.
And my youngest is --
-My only.
-Your only is three.
My youngest is three.
What is your daughter into
-She is into her dad.
-Oh.
-More than anything.
She loves him.
I don't know, Seth.
I don't know what is being three
and what is the pandemic.
Right? Like, I can't tell, like,
which is the thing
that's causing these phases.
But when I was
working on the show,
she was just alone with her da
with the whole world shut down
just hanging out, so she and him
are like this.
And the other day I was like -
she was like,
"Daddy, I love you this much."
Like, her arms were, like,
out as far as they could go.
And I -- I knew the answer
I don't know why I did it.
But I was like,
"How much do you love Mama?"
And her arms just went in
quite a bit.
[ Laughter ]
But it was still love.
It was still love.
-Hey, so this is a show
that is based on children'
books, as I mentioned.
Were you familiar with it
at all?
-I wasn't familiar with it
It was after my time as a kid.
But I did read them
after I got the part.
[ Laughs ]
In the bathtub.
-For those who aren't
familiar with it,
tell us a little bit
about the show.
-So, the show takes place
in a parallel universe.
And there's lots of cars
and they're crashing -- No
[ Laughter ]
It's a parallel universe
of an alternate timeline.
But there's an evil source
that's sending subliminal
messages out into society.
And everybody is sort of anxious
about a big emergency
that they feel like
they're perpetually in.
And the only people
who can really suss it out
and get to the bottom of
what this emergency is
and who is sending the signals
is a group of children,
which is --
that is my favorite part
because children are innocent,
you know, when they're born.
And then they turn into us
[ Laughter ]
And so this story kind of like
highlights as a superpower
the innocence that we all have
at the beginning of our lives.
-You shot this show
in Vancouver.
-Yep.
-And I've heard that you came to
the observation that Canadians
maybe don't love sarcasm
as much as
their southern neighbors.
-Yeah. I don't want to
start a war.
[ Laughter ]
But yeah.
I kind of found that.
And I don't mean
to blanket statements,
stereotype all Canadians
because I have some dear -
some of the -- you know,
Tim McAuliffe, Katie Crown
We can list
a slew of Canadians --
Jim Carrey, I don't know -
that are really funny.
But in general, I found that
the average Canadian citizen
is not very familiar
with sarcasm.
And to be fair, sarcasm is jus
a negative, nasty form of humor,
and Canadians are polite,
sweet people.
So, yeah. I would be like --
For instance,
we had to drive to a locatio
at a box store.
And it was getting
further and further away,
even though there was
identical box stores.
We finally got to
our destination.
And I looked at the driver
I was like, "I don't know.
I'm wondering
if you could drive me
a little further to
the next box store," you know?
And he just stopped
and he looked at me.
And he was like, "I'm sorry,
I don't know what you mean."
Like, he was just like,
"What is it?"
And I'm like,
"Of course you don't
because it's just
a stupid, nasty joke."
[ Laughs ]
So, yeah.
They're not really --
I promise you,
you're going to get into trouble
if you use sarcasm in Canada
Just be careful.
-Well, that's a very nice
public service announcemen
for everybody watching.
Congratulations on the show.
-If you can get there.
[ Laughter ]
Borders are closed, pal.
No one's going.
-[ Laughs ]
Thank you so much
for being here.
And I do hope next time
I can see you in person.
-Yeah. I would like to look at
your face when I'm talking
I've been staring at this stamp.
So I could look at you.
And I know you're handsome
but I'm just looking
at America now.
-Next time I'll send you a
Seth Meyers commemorative stamp.
It'll make it a little easier.
-But you'll get one.
Thanks for having me on
the last night of Conan's show
[ Laughter ]